[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING - NICHOLE &
WILLIAMS, "SHADE OF BLUES"]
KIMBERLY NICHOLE: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
KIMBERLY NICHOLE: So that's
a new tune Brad Williams
and myself wrote.
It's called "Shade of Blues."
It's an ode to my hometown
of Seattle, Washington.
Yeah, it's two of [INAUDIBLE]
honey, in the house.
I think there's two of us here.
Two black people from
Seattle in the house.
We represent the percentage, 2%.
Hello.
So, yeah.
Seattle means a lot to me.
So when Brad and I
got together-- god,
when was that Brad?
Earlier this year?
Yeah, a couple months
ago, we got together.
And I was like, you know Brad?
I really want to
do something that's
in tribute to my hometown,
the Grunge Movement and all
that good stuff.
May I curse tonight?
Am I able to curse-- oh, good.
Shit.
It's hard for me not to.
But so, I wanted to do a
song in ode to-- Seattle
has meant a great deal to
my development and evolution
as an artist.
So I definitely wanted my
new music to reflect that.
So--
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHING].
KIMBERLY NICHOLE: This next
song is also a new one.
So I'm doing new goodies
for you guys today.
This is a new one.
And Brad and I, we had
the pleasure of recording
this like, a couple weeks ago
with a live band and stuff.
Have you guys recorded
with a live band?
I mean, it's everything.
Like, old school time.
Like, I was really
in the booth singing
while the band was playing.
Like, it was the real deal.
OK, hello.
And we record it on
tape, didn't we Brad?
Tape, honey.
Hello.
That's why my ass
is broke right now.
But anyway--
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHING].
KIMBERLY NICHOLE: I need a
collection plate to go around.
But look.
We recorded the last song
I sang, "Shade of Blues,"
and this one a few weeks ago.
It sounds incredible.
So when I scurry up the funds
to mix that motherfucker,
you guys will probably hear it.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHING].
KIMBERLY NICHOLE: Ow.
So I wrote this song
with my two good friends.
The Scottish Freddie Stevenson
and the young man from Georgia.
Not the state, the country.
[INAUDIBLE]
And we wrote this one day
in the Upper West Side
in an apartment.
We had a little Grand Marnier.
And we just vibed,
honey, we just vibed.
A black girl and two white
men from Europe, honey.
Vibing.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHING].
[MUSIC PLAYING - KIMBERLY
NICHOLE, "IT AIN'T FAIR"]
[APPLAUSE]
KIMBERLY NICHOLE: All right.
It ain't fair.
The inspiration for
that song is, let's just
have a moment of realness.
You know, you're on you journey,
and you're busting your ass.
And you're working, and you're
working, and you're working.
And you're like, Jesus.
Don't let my labor be in vain.
Because honey, I'm just working,
and sweating, and tired,
and my back is hurting
from these back bends
during the show.
And I see no real results.
It ain't fair.
So that inspired that song.
The journey.
Speaking of journeys,
I have an album
called "The Yellow
Brick Journey."
She's on iTunes,
Bandcamp, Amazon.
But in the interim, I have a
freebie that my friends are
walking around with,
one of my new songs
called "Sarah the Devil."
I have a few left
overs from LA, so try
to catch one of those kids in
the-- there he is right there.
It's a pink CD.
He has a free one.
So if you catch him, get one.
How many do you have, Lonnie?
Oh, about 10.
He said about 10.
Look at that hands, Lonnie.
Get the people
with hands, honey.
Help the people out.
Give the people a CD.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHING].
KIMBERLY NICHOLE: So back
to me being from Seattle.
Born and raised.
I love my hometown.
But I remember being
a kid in Seattle
and listening to the
radio, me and my sister.
We were wee wee little girls,
and we were very small,
and we were precious,
and sweet, and innocent.
And we used to hear this song
all the time on the radio,
and we loved this song,
and we'd always sing it.
But for some reason, I couldn't
hit the notes when I was young.
And I said, you know
what, little Kim?
When you get older--
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHING].
KIMBERLY NICHOLE: I was.
I was little.
Little Kim.
Girl, when you get older
and you move on up,
when you move on up
to New York City,
make sure you add this
song to your sets.
So this is one of
my favorite songs
by one of my favorite writers.
And it's my last song.
I'm going to sing it
for you guys tonight.
[MUSIC PLAYING - 4 NON
BLONDES, "WHAT'S UP?"]
KIMBERLY NICHOLE: Can you
all all say that with me?
[ALL SINGING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
KIMBERLY NICHOLE: Thank you.
[CROWD CHEERING]
RYAN LOREN: All
right, everybody.
Please welcome Kimberly Nichole.
[APPLAUSE]
RYAN LOREN: Kimberly, I am
so happy to have you here.
You've performed here,
believe it or not,
once before everybody.
But this time, we're
doing it right.
So I can't wait
for everybody to be
hear to you sing and perform.
So thanks for being here.
I couldn't imagine a
celebration of black music
month without you.
And that's what
we're here to do.
KIMBERLY NICHOLE:
Thank you, Ryan.
RYAN LOREN: So it's
going to be incredible.
So your style is very, to me,
diverse, eclectic, and raw.
So tell us, where are you from?
Where did you come
from? [LAUGHING].
KIMBERLY NICHOLE: I was born and
raised in Seattle, Washington.
And I grew up listening to the
music my parents played when
I was a child, which was
majority gospel music and soul
music.
But I was also really like,
into the music of Seattle,
which was grunge and rock.
Those have all played
into who I am today.
RYAN LOREN: Great.
So how would you
describe your style?
KIMBERLY NICHOLE:
The rock ballerina.
AUDIENCE: Woo!
[LAUGHING]
KIMBERLY NICHOLE:
[SMACKING LIPS].
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHING].
RYAN LOREN: Awesome.
I More specifically, were
there one or two singers
you could tell us who did
inspire you growing up?
KIMBERLY NICHOLE:
Oh, my goodness.
I loved The Clark
Sisters when I was a kid.
I really loved them.
I think my mom kind of catered
my voice towards those that I
resembled, so she
really encouraged
me a lot of times to listen
to like, Gladys Knight.
And even if I got older, Sade.
But currently, those
who really inspire
me are more so like The Doors,
Jim Morrison, Sister Rosetta
Tharpe, and Outkast has really
been inspiring me lately.
So it's changed as
I've gotten older.
RYAN LOREN: Your
voice is your voice.
I don't know how to describe it.
But it's powerful, I would say.
How do you take care yourself?
How do you take
care of your voice?
KIMBERLY NICHOLE: I sleep a lot.
Yes, anyone that knows me
knows I'm big on sleeping.
So I take naps.
I do a lot of napping.
And I like to juice.
And I do a lot of
ginger as well.
RYAN LOREN: Ginger's great.
KIMBERLY NICHOLE: Yes.
RYAN LOREN: What do you juice?
KIMBERLY NICHOLE: Greens.
Kale, spinach,
apples, gala apples.
Ginger, a lot of
ginger, and carrots.
RYAN LOREN: Carrots.
Carrots.
KIMBERLY NICHOLE: Yes.
That's my favorite juice.
RYAN LOREN: Have you ever
been on a juice cleanse?
KIMBERLY NICHOLE: I've
tried, but the chicken
keeps calling me.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHING].
AUDIENCE: Speak the truth.
KIMBERLY NICHOLE: Yes, honey.
I like to eat.
RYAN LOREN: Great.
Well, that's wonderful.
So can you tell us one
thing maybe outside
of music and juicing that
you're passionate about.
KIMBERLY NICHOLE: I love my dog.
I have a puppy.
Her name is Hendricks.
RYAN LOREN: OK.
Hendricks.
KIMBERLY NICHOLE:
That's my baby.
I was in LA like,
for three days,
and I liked, missed her so much.
So that's my partner in crime.
And next week, we're
going home to Seattle.
So that's my baby.
RYAN LOREN: And she's
accompanying you.
KIMBERLY NICHOLE: Yes.
That's my girl.
RYAN LOREN: What kind of dog?
KIMBERLY NICHOLE:
She's a Shorkie.
She's a Shih Tzu and Yorkie mix.
She's a mutt.
RYAN LOREN: I love the fact
that I now know that word.
Shorkie.
All right.
Cool.
So tell us more about your
music and what's coming up.
KIMBERLY NICHOLE: Well,
I'm working on new music.
I'm so excited about it.
I'm going to do two
songs here today
during the performance piece.
I'm excited about
how I'm evolving,
what it's sounding like.
It's really inspired largely
from my childhood in Seattle.
So it's straight
ahead rock music.
Like, there's no
sugar coating it.
It's raw.
It's nasty, and it's rock.
RYAN LOREN: Good.
When did you move to New York?
And you've been here
for a little while.
What is advice you give to
people who have just got here
who are trying to do
what you're trying to do?
KIMBERLY NICHOLE:
I came here in '08.
I think New York, you
have to be very focused.
You have to have a
drive in you, and you
have to be persistent,
and just strong-headed
and have a strong will.
Because it can
really eat you up.
Like, I've had moments
where I'm like, I can't.
Jesus, please Lord,
just help me out.
But if you believe in what
you've come here to accomplish,
you can accomplish it,
but you can't do it
without having drive
and hard work behind it.
RYAN LOREN: Great.
Well, I know you do
have those things based
on knowing you for
a little while.
So I'm really happy
to have you here.
I know great great
things are in store.
And best of luck to you.
And I'm looking forward
to the performance.
KIMBERLY NICHOLE:
Thank you, Ryan.
Thank you, guys.
AUDIENCE: Woo!
Woo!
KIMBERLY NICHOLE:
Y'all have a good one.